[Musik]
etwas glanz willkommen beim ein video
das heutige video entsteht in
kooperation mit kokos und zwar geht es
heute um 10 styles von schülern die
wirklich jeder kennen also ich hab mir
einfach zehn schüler ausgesucht und die
werde ich jetzt einfach mal anhand ihrem
style nachstellen und ich bin mir
hundertprozentig sicher ihr kennt
wirklich jeden also ich kann mich da
komplett an meine schulzeit zurück
erinnern auch wenn es eigentlich nicht
lang her
ich will gar nicht einlagern wir fangen
sofort waren wenn es ihr gefällt das
noch nach oben da und viel spaß
[Musik]
der switch
alex ich habe voll das problem
ach guten morgen was ist denn los in 10
minuten beginnt doch die schule ich habe
meinen rucksack vergessen ich brauche
zugleich sein kann wird der hetze auch
mal dran denken können also meine
hausaufgaben bekommst du nicht die
lässig vor der streber
scheiß auf schule zugute wie z
der pumpe
pro aktie nicht hier in deutschland so
aus ich war den herbst werden zwei
wochen in südamerika und ich dachte mich
bringen das war mal ein bisschen mit in
die schule
stell dir einfach alle ferien im urlaub
ist gut das ist eine unserer business
school.de aufzüge die treppe richtig
gern laufen
sie keine auf der hand zog mensch wo ich
schwöre gar keinen bock auf schule egal
ob sie die heißen typen gestern wieder
tut sie
[Musik]
das partyvolk ii
ich will leute aber nicht in die schule
gehen weil die ärgert mich wieder ich
traue mich aber nie
kannst du mich nicht abholen kommen ich
mein ich gehe da nicht wieder hin
andere gehen immer nur auf mich drauf
das opfer war gar keinen bock auf schule
macht
so leute was geht ab heute bin ich auf
dem weg zur schule und ich dachte mir
ich nehme euch einfach mal mit weil so
ein schultag ist natürlich schon
interessant da fällt mir gerade auf ich
habe irgendwie geld in meiner tasche
alter 100 euro flyer ich bin ja youtuber
der youtuber ja heute bevor ihr weg
schaltet schreibt doch erstmal einen typ
also mit denen ihr euch so am besten
identifizieren können in den kommentaren
interessiert mich mal und dann habe ich
natürlich zum abschluss jetzt hier noch
den rucksack von kuka zu den könnt ihr
gewinnen wenn ihr bock habt und das ist
da jetzt runter gefallen und was ihr
dafür tun müsst ist dann nach oben
abonnieren es nicht ihr müsst einfach
mal ein kommentar schreiben
in welcher klasse seit und was ihr
lieblingsfach ist und nicht automatisch
an der verlosung teil ich wünsche euch
allen viel glück schreibt die kommentare
absolut und wenn ihr bock harte checks
auf jeden fall mal die kuka so
facebook-seite ab da gibt es doch viele
andere coole rücksäcke ist einfach mal
in der video bestellung verleger jack
tisch macht ansonsten bassist mit diesem
video ich hoffe natürlich jetzt hat euch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben und wir
sondern bestimmt morgen oder übermorgen
1 nur kognitiv drei leute